So we have all our bands.
>> Yup
>> And I want to start putting them on
stages. They have to, they have to play.
>> Right.
>> Right. So I'm going to go into these records. Okay, so here's
the band, and the stage field is blank, as is set time.
>> Yep. And let's say we want to play, they're
going to play at what, 10 a.m., at stage four stage.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so that's good.
but what if I actually wanted them to play at
two different set time? Like, you know, one at 10:00 a.m.,
and maybe again at 11:00 or maybe at a totally different
stage? Is there a way to do that? It feels like
I would have to create an entirely new band or something,
a new record. That's turning a relationship into something a little
bit more complicated than just a simple one to many. So,
let me actually show you on the tablet what I mean.
>> Okay.
>> We're starting off with, we have our stage records.
And I'm only representing it as one stage box, but this could be any of the
stages that we have. And then each of these stages has a specific time we can
book them for. So like, 10 a.m., 11 a.m., 12 p.m., etcetera.
>> Sure
>> And then, for each of these time slots, you could have any sort of band
playing there. So, let's say we had you know, our first band playing at 10 a.m.,
but then for your second band, you want them playing at 11 and 12.
>> Oh, okay. Yeah, you're right, this
is getting more complicated as a data model.
>> So this is clearly not how we represent something in sales force.
>> Right.
>> Instead of now having a one to
many relationship, we have a many to many relationship.
Where a stage can have many bands But bands
can be playing at multiple stages at many times.
>> Right.
>> We're no
longer tracking you know, what stage are the bands playing at, but it's more-so
what time are they playing at those
stages. Because now there's another unique classification there.
>> Mm. So we've added this sort of like intermediate object.
>> Exactly.
>> And what we'd call that intermediate object in
Salesforce is a junction object And what a junction
object does is it represents every unique instance that
we relate a band record to a stage record.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
But what would, this isn't how we draw our scheme
in SalesForce, so, what would this actually look like in SalesForce?
>> Right. Before, we had just stages and bands.
>> Right. And the relationship had that little
line with the three forks at the end.
>> Right, our stage had many bands. But now, we
have stages, bands and this junction object called Set Time.
>> Okay.
>> How do
you think that this relationship will look, when mapping it out?